the Palestinian president Mahmoud Abbas
has arrived in Turkey for talks with
President Richard erdogan they are
expected to discuss economic
Partnerships and recent Israeli military
incursions in the occupied West Bank
erdogan has called for a two-state
solution he also restored diplomatic
relations with Israel last year
so we're joined by rasool Sardar who is
in the capital of Ankara rasool it's
good to talk to you what are you
expecting from the meeting
well the the Palestinian leader Mahmoud
Abbas has just arrived to the
presidential Palace and now a meeting
between Mahmoud abbasa and president
erdon of Turkey is on the way so we are
expecting them to come up roughly around
one hour later for a joint presser the
people familiar with this year are
saying that in terms of the Practical
results not a significant meeting and
visit however symbolically it is quite
important the reason for that is
Turkey's recent approachment with Israel
so we know that last year Isaac as of
the Israeli president has visited turkey
and that has gained a momentum for their
approachment the recovery of the
relations between Ankara and Tel Aviv so
after that we have seen that that the
prime minister of Israel also has came
here the Turkish foreign minister
visited Israel so now this has created a
concern particularly from the
Palestinian side whether it's Turkish
reproachment with Israel is going to
come at the cost of its relations with
Palestine or not that's why symbolically
now that the this visit is very much
important mamuta bus has been invited by
President erdogan and now turkey Ankara
wants to show to Palestinians that their
relations with Israel is not going to
come at the cost of their relations with
the Palestinians and Palestine so today
this is a meeting of reassuring
Palestinian Authority that turkey
support for Palestine and Palestinians
is going to continue and broadly
speaking how would you assess the
relationship as it is right now between
turkey and the Palestinian Authority
it's quite an integrated relation so
turkey for a long time has been one of
the most vocal supporter of Palestine
both domestically and also in the
international platform several platforms
and also together has been one of the
leading countries in terms of delivering
in humanitarian Aid to the besieged
areas particularly Gaza and also the
West Bank as well just remember in 2010
the reason the trick is Revelations got
deteriorated was a Turkish Med a
humanitarian Aid Convoy the flotilla my
marmara that has been attacked by Israel
then it has deteriorated the relation
between Ankara and Tel Aviv the reason
for that was turkey's commitment to to
Gaza so right after that as well turkey
has been quite critical toward Israel
and Israelis policies over the
Palestinians and also cap continuous
political economical uh supports and
also diplomatic supports as well that's
why this relation is very much important
for both sides symbolically and
practically as well
is here to secure that this support is
going to continue and of course both
sides are very much willing to show that
this is not a matter of international
relations only for turkey but it's a
very much sensitive issue domestically
as well and everyone definitely want to
build on that build on on that reporting
from Ankara al-jazeera's rasool sirdar
thank you
a magnitude 5.5 earthquake has hit
Southern turkey near the city of Adana
Tremors have been reported in some
neighboring cities including hattai and
gaziantep the European Mediterranean
seismological Center says it is the 13th
earthquake recorded in three days